[Music]
foreign
then for Saturday night's press preview
first look at what is on the front pages
of tomorrow's papers and this evening
we'll see what's making the headlines
with Christina Patterson journalist and
orthat who is joined by Jake
wallace-simons and it's at the Jewish
Chronicle a very good evening to both of
you I will chat in a moment after we've
had a look at those front pages let's
begin with the Sunday Telegraph shall we
the chief of Defense staff has said Army
staff are not spare capacity for
striking staff that's on the front page
Express reports the Home Secretary has
vowed to end migrant deaths by tackling
criminal gangs
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex want to
sit down with the royal family to
discuss their grievances after the
release of their Netflix documentary
that's on the front of the Sunday Times
similarly The Sun Also reports on Harry
and Megan's demands
while the star on Sunday has a story
about the late pop singer George Michael
and don't forget by scanning the QR code
you can see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
Sunday's papers while you listen and
watch us discussing them and we're
joining up by Christina Patterson and
Jake what is Simon's great to see you
both um let's start shall we with the
front of the Sunday Telegraph
interesting angle this Christina isn't
it we know that the armed forces are
going to be brought in it's part of the
government's contingency planning to
help out during these strikes doing
things like driving ambulances but the
chief of Defense staff is saying that it
is perilous that's his word to expect
Personnel to be used routinely for that
role
absolutely and and I think I'm I'm
really pleased he's spoken out it's an
admiral Admiral for Tony eradican I
don't know if that's how you pronounce
it who has said that uh the armed forces
are not spare capacity and I think that
is how they are often used or they are
being used in this situation by the
government and and we should remember
that most people in the armed forces
earn considerably less than most people
in the public sector and have had much
lower pay Rises than most people in the
public sector they are not allowed to
strike and they are being forced because
you have to do what you're told in the
armed forces more than in most jobs
um to cover for people who are striking
and will therefore some of them miss
Christmas missing their families so it's
a tough ask and it's also
um an ask that seems to suggest that
there's masses and spare capacity and
people just sitting around doing nothing
well they are already doing doing jobs
and they can't step in to become
paramedics I mean they may be able to
drive a vehicle but that is not the same
as being a paramedic it's not the same
as being a member of the Border forces
and it's certainly not the same as being
a nurse or somebody working in a e so I
think he's quite right to point this out
and I think that the government uses
they they always want they always talk
about the military when they want to
sound Macho and tough what they should
be doing is sitting down and negotiating
and not pretending that the end that the
pay review body is an independent body
because it was working to the
government's brief and what it has
suggested is within the boundaries that
the government has given it so quite
right to is what I would say yeah we'll
broaden it out in a second but just get
your thoughts Jake on on this story in
the telegraph just looking at the
figures the standard wage for a soldier
is 21 424 pounds for a paramedic 27 055.
um as as Christine says it it will be a
tough ask for for some of those soldiers
that's right I mean those two figures
that you quoted were the lowest figures
so for a private in the r21 000 and then
for a paramedic after I think it was two
years experience 27. the average nurse's
pay is 37 000 pounds the average pay in
Britain is 34 000 so they're being paid
slightly above the average
um I just feel uh overall that my
patience uh is running out with the
nurse's strike and I think I'd probably
speak for a lot of people in Britain I
mean myself my fiance had a problem with
her chest the other day
um and she went to the doctor doctor
couldn't tell whether it was a clot or a
collapsing lung but she couldn't get an
x-ray which she needed because the
nurses were on strike I think these
experiences being replicated up and down
the country and people are going to
begin to become rather cross and this is
another dimension to the story whereby
the soldiers are being told to come in
and pick up the slag of course as
Christina pointed out they're not fully
trained to do so you can't magically
turn a soldier into a nurse or into a
firefighter or into a paramedic or
whatever and so they're not really
equipped to do so and they've got a job
of their own we have an army for a
reason uh you know we don't have nurses
to fight Wars we don't have soldiers to
do nursing and it does seem to me as if
you know soldiers are not legally
allowed to strike because their job is
so important to the security of the
nation that they have to do their jobs
whatever and I'm beginning to feel that
the same should really apply to nurses
whose jobs are no less vital to the
health functioning and security of our
country yeah it's a debate that is being
had isn't it Christina at the moment
that nurses perhaps shouldn't be allowed
to strike where do you stand on that
well I I my heart goes out to you Jake
and your fiance because that is an
absolutely Dreadful situation if you
can't get the help you need and of
course many people did have their
appointments canceled and they missed
out on getting treatment they really
needed and the fact that it has the word
routine in front of it doesn't mean it's
important and and won't make a
difference to your life that you don't
get it
I have to say
dissentment according to the
old 60 of the country do support the
nurses and and the support from the
nurses have actually gone up but two two
percentage points so um as a country our
patients for the nurses is not waning
and generally speaking nurses are not
well paid for the work they do and in
real term since 2010 they've actually
had a significant pay cut so I
absolutely do support them and I think
they are doing this very very
reluctantly and they have
um made taken measures to ensure that
you know basic life-saving treatment is
given to people but of course people do
suffer and presumably some people will
die as a result of this strike which is
tragic and I I do think that they do
have the right to strike they have the
right to withdraw their labor and most
of them are doing it because they're
working conditions there is so many uh
vacancies unfilled in nursing that their
their working life has become next to
Impossible
Christine sorry to interrupt but when
when Richie sunak as he says in the sun
tomorrow
um all massive pay hikes would do is
kick us into an inflation spiral and
would all be worse off what do you say
to that
well I think I think there is room for
negotiation with the nurses I think it
was probably not very wise of them to go
in asking for 19 when inflation is
around 10 10 because that does look
unreasonable but then the four percent
ish they've been offered it also looks
unreasonable and I I think there has to
be some middle ground and in fact I
think probably that we will end up with
some kind of Middle Ground I think there
are there is talk a foot of of talks now
because I think the government realized
that if they're up against the nurses
they are actually going to that in terms
of public support the government is
unlikely to win on this one I think
there are different feelings about
different
um people for example you know train the
the transport Union striking I think
there are different levels of sympathy
there but for nurses currently I think
the level of sympathy is high and I
think they have to reach some kind of
settlement okay and just finally on this
let's bring in the front page of the
Observer I think if we can nurses pledge
tougher new strikes as NHS crisis
deepens I mean this is also an issue
Jake isn't it that if if both sides
don't sit round the table it could get
even worse as we head further into
winter
that's right I mean I don't want to uh
in any way suggest I don't have any
sympathy for nurses who do an
extraordinarily difficult job under very
challenging circumstances which are only
more difficult since the pandemic than
they were before but you know soldiers
do a difficult job too uh you know a lot
of people do a difficult job out of
public service out of a sense of
vocation and the uh what nurses need to
do is begin to think about the
implications on patients it's their duty
to serve patients just as it's soldiers
duties to serve our country and
Christina did say that support public
support stands at about 60 percent right
now it was a few weeks ago at 80 percent
when the strikes were first mooted so it
is waning
um I mean obviously it fluctuates
um but I think that what we really need
to remember is that you know my fiance's
experience is is one of millions around
the country and people are really
suffering from um from a bad service at
the NHS and they have been since the
pandemic you know waiting lists longer
than they've been in living memory
pretty much
um ambulances you know overburdened the
a e departments spilling out into the
streets uh things are bad in the NHS and
to choose this moment to to strike you
know whatever however difficult your job
is as a nurse I think is the wrong thing
to do okay let's go for a change of
topic front of the Sunday Times uh also
on the front of the sun on Sunday as
well
um Harry and Megan Christina are after a
a royal Summit a bit like the one that
negozi Fulani and Lady Hussey had this
week where they sat down and discussed
their Grievances and and actually Bowl
accounts everything seemed to go quite
well now Harry and Megan wants an
apology from the palace
I'm sorry to laugh but I mean I mean
look I I've seen the first three
episodes of the Netflix series I have
not sat down to watch the other three I
had the excuse of having covered for the
first one um and I don't have covert now
and life is frankly too short but I I
just think
of self-knowledge is pretty breathtaking
I'm sure they they feel they have
enormous green well they clearly feel
they have enormous grievances the entire
world now knows how deep those
grievances are
um I think to to wash your dirty Linen
in public the way they have done and
make huge amounts of money out of it and
then claim you are the wronged parties
that really is not the way to go if you
genuinely want to solve a family
um a family sort of you know problem of
some kind then you talk to people you
don't [ __ ] about them or Diss them in
public you don't make vast amounts of
money out of them you don't make
allegations that those people don't feel
able to respond to because traditionally
the royal family does not respond to
those kind of things the royal family is
a very very weird institution it's very
anachronistic it must be very difficult
to be in it I think you know you do grow
up in a gilded cage I have full sympathy
for anyone Born Into the royal family
and it's exposed to that level of public
scrutiny but really the time comes when
you think enough already can you perhaps
stop the complaining I mean make your
choice make your choice if you want to
be free of the royal family drop the
titles
be in your 16 bathroom mansion and just
you know get a job and stop dissing
every single person who you know once
loved you because really it's it's not a
very attractive uh spectacle I didn't
know they had 16 bathrooms that's
something I've learned tonight Jake
16 bathrooms I mean yeah and what can
you do with 16 bathrooms I mean it's the
most undignified and unedifying
spectacle I mean for any family to air
its dirty laundry in public like this uh
is really ugly and ill-advised and makes
reconciliation much more difficult uh
let alone the royal family and let alone
when it's done via Netflix I mean it's
the most extraordinary sort of story
that's unraveling before our eyes and I
think that for Harry and Megan to now
demand a summit and to demand an apology
from the royal family
um is is uh you know to use a um a
Yiddish word about you know the peak of
hutzpah I don't think anybody in the
country would really think that they
would either deserve or an apology
um or stand a good chance of getting
this Summit that they seem to desire and
to draw a parallel between the meeting
between Susan Hussey and negozi Fulani
and their situation just shows such a
level of myopia it really does seem
they've disappeared at their own egos
okay
um we've just got uh a minute or so to
discuss the final story it's on the
front of the Sunday Express I was down
in Dover uh this week uh for that awful
story about four people drowning in the
channel uh Christina clearly something
does need to be done to stop further
tragedies like that
um what's the Home Secretary saying
as always that she is going to be the
person to solve this and um Good Luck to
her I mean it certainly needs solving
because this constant flow of people
risking their lives and losing their
lives it really is tragic and at the
moment an awful lot of them
um are not uh have no claim to be in the
UK many of them have been coming from
Albania which is a safe country and they
have no reason to be claiming Asylum or
be housed at the expense of the British
taxpayer
um but there are other people who who
are escaping terrible situations but the
fact that I mean many many people in the
world are in terrible situations and
it's currently only the ones who pay
um the Smugglers who managed to get to
the UK so it is a dreadful situation but
sowella breatherman is very very good on
the rhetoric uh not so good uh with her
personal emails and you know very bad at
solving the problem so let's see how far
she gets but I think less talk and more
action would probably be appreciated
okay we'll perhaps get your thoughts on
that in the next hour Jake we must leave
you there for the moment time to go to a
break uh coming up this picture on the
front page of the Sunday Times of Gallup
Southgate and the story about why the
England managers staying put
[Music]
uh welcome back part two of The Press
preview Jake and Christina still here
and let's talk about this story on the
front of the Sunday Telegraph Jake uh
first time cocaine and cannabis users
will avoid prosecution uh police drawing
up new plans
that's right this is a this is placing
the the police and public health
professionals on a collision course with
the government because the government
the home secretary's uh policy is to
ramp up the level of punishment missed
out to people who not just Supply drugs
but take them as well
um with the aim to deter uh the use of
drugs but public health health
professionals have pointed out that that
doesn't really work a more effective
strategy is to treat you know light
users first-time users and so forth as a
public health matter to divert them into
schemes that educate them and provide
Roots out of drug use and thus save
police time and to me it seems like a uh
a very practical solution and a good one
you know the police are stretched enough
as it is you know trying to keep on top
of burglaries and other types of
low-level crime uh it does seem like a
good idea to to take a pragmatic
approach to reducing drug use uh
whatever way you can and it seems like
if it works I think it should be done
but um I mean this already happens
doesn't it Christina um 14 police forces
in England and Wales already operate and
no prosecution strategy
yes and but the government again always
well you know likes to show that it has
had enough of the experts and prefers to
wend its own sweet way because it thinks
that by being anti-drugs and uh sounding
tough on crime they always think will
make them sound very Macho and tough and
they always think that's a vote winner
and it's a calculation that is made
particularly it has to be said towards
for example red walls each because there
is a sense that in more working-class
communities ironically in the
communities where there are higher
levels of crime that being tough on
crime in the way that they uh suggest
which always means you know longer
prison sentences you know Zero Tolerance
of this that and the other unfortunately
it never works and if you really want to
solve the problem of drugs or any number
or very complicated societal issues you
should listen to The Experts and as Jake
says the um Public Health evidence shows
that
um actually the approach where you don't
criminalize people for a first time
offense is much more effective because
that then you lock people into the
criminal justice system and it just
perpetuates the whole thing yeah our
home office spokesman said yesterday
that drugs ruin lives and devastate
communities which is why the government
is committed to tackling both the supply
and demand for drugs um and let's finish
with this news front of the Sunday Times
uh Jake I don't know if you've been
following the the World Cup in Qatar but
Gareth Southgate
um was uh sort of mulling mulling things
over about whether it was going to stay
on but he is now ready to tell the fa he
will stay as head coach
that's right I mean it seems no
exaggeration to say that guy Southgate
seems to think about leaving uh almost
you know every year at the very least
and this seems to be the latest uh bout
of soul searching he received a lot of
abuse apparently
um recently uh online I suppose and has
been questioning his position but now
seems like he's going to stay I mean
look the England performance uh at the
at the World Cup in Qatar fizzled out we
had High Hopes which were sustained for
a while but then it was a case of same
old England the curse of the penalty
back again uh and unfortunately uh
England becoming true to form we're
still trying to break free of those
years of hurt and and and we're trying
to bring football home but it seems like
Gareth Southgate still feels like he's
the man to do it and I think the country
will be behind him on that there's a lot
of affection for him uh despite the um
the eventual eventual fizzling out of
our campaign in Qatar and I know
Christina you've not been following
events in Qatar that closely but I think
this will be a popular decision won't it
well as you know Jonathan I'm I'm no
great fan of football but I'm a very big
fan of Garrett Southgate I think he's a
lovely man
um he has great integrity he's very very
good at building team spirit and the
members of the England football team
really like him the British public
really like him and I think he's a man I
think the reason he considers his
position is because he knows how
unpopular you are if you are an England
coach and you don't lead your team's
Victory which is of course the General
State of things and um and he wants to
make sure that you know people want him
in the job and people do want him in the
job so you know good for Gareth um we
look forward to him I don't know having
a nice time I really don't care I'm
afraid whether he didn't win anything
[Laughter]
they're nice men there are lovely young
people on that team and if it makes them
happy to win then I would love them to
win I remember the last time we were on
you're saying this exactly the same
thing about Marcus rashford you said I
don't know much about football but I
know that Mark as well
I love the characters I I have no
interest in the game Jonathan but I I
think then I think they're lovely
characters I mean look at Marcus
rashford's campaigning work in Charities
and for School meals and all the rest of
it I think he's a wonderful wonderful
young person and I think a number of
them are very very impressive people all
right we'll leave it there thank you
both